the International Court of Justice has
ordered the United States to lift some
of its sanctions on Iran the ruling
covers restrictions linked to
humanitarian goods as well as Civil
Aviation there aren't file the complaint
in July saying that by pulling out of
the Iranian nuclear deal the US had
breached another Accord struck back in
1955 let's cross live to Charlotte
Dubinsky in Paris for the latest
Charlotte's what does this mean now for
Iran US relations obviously a very big
step here by that Court well this is a
victory for Tehran and that's exactly
how Tirana taking it the International
Court of Justice the ICJ has made that
ruling today saying that the sanctions
imposed some of them by the Trump
administration back in May
earlier this year actually now need to
be removed and it specified what type of
sanctions need to be removed those are
the sanctions on things that impede
medical equipment medical aid going into
the country also foodstuffs going into
the country as well as things such as
spare parts and associated services for
the Civil Aviation services so
essentially parts needed for planes to
fly in the country and internationally
now it also talked about removing the
sanctions of the transfer of funds that
are not subject to any restrictions and
it also said that neither party so
neither Iran neither the US should do
anything to aggravate the other in this
particular case now it also as you
mentioned there talked about the treaty
of amity which was in 1955 this was a
treaty that was signed between the two
countries the USA and Iran when they had
closer relations and that treaty the
International Court of Justice says has
been broken by these sanctions this is a
treaty that was looking to improve the
economic relations and the consular
relations between the two countries and
to have more investment and mutual trade
between the countries now as you
mentioned those sanctions were imposed
originally back in May earlier this year
by the Trump administration at the same
time as the
illustration decided that it was going
to withdraw from the Iranian nuclear
called something that was signed by
Trump's predecessor Donna but
predecessor Barack Obama and this is
what Donald Trump had to say back in May
when he announced those sanctions
America will not be held hostage to
nuclear blackmail powerful sanctions
will go into full effect if the regime
continues its nuclear aspirations it
will have bigger problems than it has
ever had before
well withdrawal from the Iranian nuclear
code as signed by his predecessor Barack
Obama was widely condemned by the
international community our countries
such as Russia France Germany China and
the UK all said it was wrong for the
Trump administration to withdraw from
that nuclear accord now the judgment
today has been welcomed by Tehran with
the foreign ministry stating that in its
judgment that means that Iran is right
and the sanctions imposed by the US on
its people and its citizens are cruel
and illegal there's also been reaction
from the foreign minister of Iran on
Twitter another failure for the
sanctions addicted US government and a
victory for the rule of law it's
imperative for the international
community to collectively counter malign
u.s. unilateralism well this decision
whilst being binding and not able to be
appealed will be particularly difficult
to enforce
now that's because back in the 1980s the
United States decided withdrawal from
being compulsorily as subject to these
jurisdictions in fact it will take them
on a case-by-case basis we're still
waiting at the moment to get reaction
from the White House from the Trump
administration as to what they think of
this judgment and we know that at the
moment there are still plans on the
table to have another round of sanctions
against Iran which are due to be
enforced next month indeed all eyes now
on that the future of that deal and on
those negotiate
Charlotte Dubinski they're from Paris
with the latest update now the Royal
nuclear deal was signed three years ago
between Tehran and five permanent UN
Security Council members as well as
Germany it took almost a decade to
thrash out that deal its main aim was to
put an end to a long lasting standoff
over Iran's nuclear activities and
discuss the issue further crossing live
now to Abbas as learning from Iran's
Tasman News Agency thanks for joining us
sir good to have you on the program
obviously very big news today do you
think this ruling of the International
Court of Justice was expected or has it
come to you as a surprise well thank you
for having me in fact this ruling by the
UN top court is considered kind of a
victory which was welcomed by the
Iranian Foreign Ministry today in Tehran
however I was hearing that the diplomats
in Tehran we're optimist toward reaching
a favorable result from the court to
rule in favor of Iran
however they were not sure that what the
ruling of the court could be but they
were hopeful that they could reach a
good ruling from the U the court side
and how do you think the u.s. is going
to respond we're still obviously waiting
for official comments from the White
House from Washington doesn't have to
comply with the ruling or can it
effectively say this doesn't concern us
we'll still do our own thing well what
we can expect from the American
administration is that they will have a
position against an opposite to the
court as they have done to the other
international commitments or
organizations but I think this ruling is
important because the United States has
tried to put pressure on Iran on
different fronts the first was legal
front the first was the technical front
by pressuring the IAEA International
Atomic Energy organization they wanted
to put pressure on the agency to derail
the nuclear deal but the agency issue
12 reports confirming Iran's compliance
to its commitments under the nuclear
deal the second phase were to put
pressure on Iran politically which the
climax was in the United Nations General
Assembly and Security Council meeting
presided by President Trump in which we
saw that the Americans went into more
political isolation themselves by seeing
and facing the opposition from there
even their own allies and the last one
was a legal front between Iran and the
United States of which the ruling I
think indicates that the Americans have
been more isolated and Iran is trying to
use these three fronts in order to make
sure that it can also benefit the
economic front as well while the
Americans are trying to put pressure on
the other countries in order to make you
run economically isolated and I think
this is this indicates the importance of
the ruling of the ICJ which can help
other countries in order to bypass the
sanctions against Iran and thus this can
give the legal basis to other countries
in order to try to circumvent those
sanctions and try to work with Iran the
decision of course really concerns
specific sanctions doesn't it those
touching upon humanitarian trade civil
aviation sanctions as well does that
mean the other sanctions on Iran are
legal and legitimate now what everyone
believes is that the approach by the
American administration is illegitimate
and unlawful and the sanctions are used
as a level leverage to put pressure on
Iran in order to behave in a way that is
desirable to the United States that's
why you Ron believes that those
pressures and sanctions are not
legitimate and the issue that the
humanitarian commodities which have been
referred by the UN court is that they
are they have the high priority
internationally hanging in here
manatorian aspect but it doesn't mean
that the other sanctions are legitimate
and because this is the primary ruling
by the court and they will proceed to
consider the case in future and this
proceeding in future can indicate that
Iran might get the argument that the
other sanctions which are due to be
re-imposed are illegitimate as well and
yet the final decision by the court
remains to be issued in future after
they have their own considerations in
future and just briefly of course it's
not the only country to view these these
sanctions as illegitimate and you know
detrimental to the world economy
president putin has expressed similar
sentiment in fact ii use countries as
well they're finding ways around the
sanctions to do business with Iran with
Iranian companies given that context and
given this court ruling do you think
this is or could be the beginning of the
end for full sanctions on Iran well as
you said this is not just the American
sanctions against Iran today we're
seeing that the Americans have imposed
sanctions against Russia against Turkey
and other countries as well in addition
to the sanctions they have imposed
tariffs against even their own allies
and countries like China and other
countries like Canada as well so I think
this can give the pretext to other
countries to rethink their policies
toward their cooperation with the United
States and they will I think will think
twice before cooperating with Americans
and this can result in bringing new
mechanisms or new financial
international system in order to
decrease the Dominions of the Americans
over this international system and I
think this can be a beginning for
different countries in order to decrease
and lessen the influence of the
Washington over the financial system in
the world and in as a result this can
conclude in
more independent countries in European
continent as well as in the east and
west and this can in the longer run the
decrease the influence and impact of
sanctions against Iran and other
countries like Russia Turkey and so on
and I think this is a pretext for
different countries to cooperate against
the United States and this is not the
issue or story of Iran versus the United
States but this seems with the policy we
are seeing from the Trump side this is
the United States versus the world
you